declinism about Britain is just wrong
it's always been wrong in the past
and it's wrong today
some of the Gloom is based on statistics
that don't reflect the whole picture
like every G7 country our growth was
slower in the years after the financial
crisis than before it
but since 2010 the UK has grown faster
than France Japan and Italy not at the
bottom but right in the middle of the
pack
since the brexit referendum we've grown
at about the same rate as Germany
yes we've not returned to pre-pandemic
employment or output levels but an
economy that contracted 20 percent
in a pandemic
still has nearly the lowest unemployment
for half a century
and whilst our public sector continues
to recover more slowly than we would
like from the pandemic strengthening the
case for reform
our private sector has grown seven and a
half percent in the last year
yes inflation has risen
but it's still lower than in 14 EU
countries with interest rates Rising
more slowly than in the U.S or Canada
and yes we have to improve our
productivity but output our work is now
higher than pre-pandemic and last week a
survey of Business Leaders by PWC said
the UK was the third most attractive
country for CEOs expanding their
businesses
economists and journalists know you can
spend a long time arguing the toss on
statistics
but the strongest grounds for optimism
comes not from debating this or that way
of analyzing data
but from what we've been hearing about
this morning our long-term prospects
because when it comes to the Innovation
industries that will shape and Define
this century
the UK is powerfully positioned to play
a leading role